[Music]
hi everyone how's it going hopefully you
guys were right with me in twitch
channel a little while ago and now
that's good switch to YouTube
we are gonna respect the poll and so
thank you for your votes we're gonna
focus more and middlegame and end game
rather than specifically on my rope see
and so I'm gonna show you this position
first of all let's do about 10 to 12
puzzles that are very cool and some of
you might have seen similar teams and
the twitch channel a little few hours
ago and so ideally we're gonna do some
of these puzzles and then I'm gonna show
you how to beat Kasparov in 13 steps so
yeah this one is boxing move feel free
to start calculating and making
candidate moves and let me know what you
think is the right move I'm going to be
monitoring the chat from the other
computer
hi everyone I see a lot of familiar
usernames
yeah so the title of how to beat
Kasparov in 13 steps is actually this is
a game from one of my favorite books
Giants of strategy and I finally found a
book online as well because I had the
physical copy which is packed away
somewhere in my dorm room and so yeah I
have I I'm kind of taking the cool title
and it's very catchy and it actually
shows you step 1 you do that step 2 you
do that it's very cool so I have ideas
with F 5 and C 5 so yeah maybe calculate
and see so it's not about it's not about
what it's not about like a tactic or
it's not like a mating shoe it's not
like that it's more about what do you
think your position needs right now so
if you think your position needs f5 sure
if you think your position needs c5 sure
so it's for your understanding just to
tell me what you think your position
needs
see five does look very nice but if you
say see five you have to be prepared for
the exchange because if see five most
likely the logical move is to take
Bishop takes p7 rook takes b7 and what
do you think black will do next whites
will do next
whites but pushed upon wise could defend
the pawn so that's the main thing that
you should consider if you're suggesting
cc5 oh hi Tracy
wait why aren't you at your club account
so I agree I agree that f5 looks a
little bit weird and so the problem with
five is that simply and when you enter
the endgame it gives you it gives your
opponents some targets like key 6 to use
and the other thing to consider is if a
right now this Bishop is much more
efficient than this Bishop so it's a
good idea to try and exchange it off so
the only thing is you should calculate
this after c5 while taking is the only
move because if the bishop goes away d4
falls right so the only thing to kind of
seriously consider is take take and then
if it comes to D - you always have route
t7 and it's some sort of a transposition
because eventually this d5 is going to
happen and you're going to get into this
position and after take take do you
think this position is good for white
good for black is the draw
so yeah again like I said this is not a
tactic this is not a super-steep
strategy it's just understanding
understanding what's your position needs
and doing dads it is it is very stuck
it's super Dhiraj so basically you just
bring in your king and there's not much
black can do white can do black has this
pressure over here a little bit but
can't really do much about it
white has some pressure could maybe
bring in the king up until here but
there is not much hope for either of
them so it is a draw it is possible
black could keep pushing on d5 but it's
highly unlikely to actually win it let's
say even if you bring in some King and
stuff how are you going to actually try
to put more pressure here like you would
eventually try to play something like
this and white could just play a four
and it's it is it is dryish so yeah I
agree okay so this was the first
position already raising a lot of
comments and challenges huh so what do
you think about this one this one is
White's tomb of Tokyo and game some
strategy and endgame
hi storm
so what do you think your position needs
in this position now also who do you
think is better why it's our black
hi Raymond
um so the idea of a four is very very
nice good job but you have to prepare
for it you can't it's it's not the best
to just play a four right away and so
knowing that how can you prepare for it
oh I forgot to mention these puzzles are
from a selection of the archer Yusupov
games he he wrote nine books like three
different books series and he did these
actually helps my chess a lot I did all
of those nine books so like third series
like there are three series of three
books the first one of each series is
kind of doable and easy right now for
most of you or for those of you who are
just making the transits to intermediate
then that's actually good for you the
first set this is the second books third
books are actually pretty hard takes me
a while to try and figure those out so
you probably want to play b3 yes b3 is
the right to move and so the idea is you
just simply want to push for whoops a4
and so let's say black tries to play a
little tricky what do you do next
yeah how would you use up if he's a very
great author and a chess player
so Allah say rookie five your first
things instinct should be to move the
king somewhere
uh-huh how Philippines Wow thank you for
watching
your classics is interesting but your
first instinct should be to move the
king especially because this might be
coming up so instinct move the king
thank you Tim Alison very nice of you to
say so I'm glad to be here too
yes King d3
very well done you activate your king
you take away some squares from the
knight and so are you guys familiar with
how it's a cool idea to have the bishop
against the the Knights like this right
because this bishop against the night
it's kind of paralyzes both pieces but
the knight more because the bishop is
still controlling a lot of the squares
but the Knights has a lot of trouble
drunk jumping around so let's say black
plays f5 and is pushing for more
possibly so what do you want to do your
opponent's wants to play f5 you put f5
wants to play f4 what is the first thing
you want to do
instinct what does your gut tell you
your opponent wants to put f4 how do you
not let him g3 yes great proud of all
your guts
why not Knight c5 um I mean Knight c5
first of all what do you do after maybe
king up you have 97 well the first thing
is that these are tricky and games so it
is if you go to the rook hand game the
King is much more White King is much
more activated than blacks Kings so
that's automatically slightly better for
white so as black you wouldn't want to
enter that so just by eyeballing it
that's that's the reason the rook
endgame would be better for white so f5g
three black tries to bring in the King
what do you do with white there is there
is a there is a delay in the video 24
seconds of delay
I see if I was check so
okay what do you want to do with white
yes good job Nixon
so route 86 Black has their limited
options before seems to be the only one
that actually keeps the pun now what do
you do all of your gonna find this
I mean f4o
delay never mind so after a before you
could potentially you could potentially
do something that's if you wanted to do
from yes tan qa4 so now this is getting
kind of bad for black because this is a
clear targets and white is going to go
after it
so the best thing black could do is to
try and give a check which you do King D
for it is you have to be very careful
with these little tricks because if you
were to take right now this is still a
better rookie and game for white but
rock n games are very very slippery and
ideally you don't want to give that
chance to your opponent so that is why
instead of entering the rook endgame you
do king d4 now do you think the king d4
is good or bad
so after king before the best thing is
you definitely have to calculate are
taking the rook and somehow you would
have to calculate some takes for black
because the one of the takes is Knight
takes a six the other take could be rook
takes III and there are no real there
are no viable checks and something like
ninety seven doesn't really count
it's just awkward you just have work a
seven so you could if take you just take
here and f5 is falling Bishop b6 Bishop
a5 is coming so Knight takes a six is
not a viable option what about rook
takes III well you guys think you
suppose that after rook takes III
so after 63
yeah yep
and Ricky seven pretty much the only one
take take
King takes e5 and King in warfare
winning endgame yep so this is how
here's above beat Anand so how about
this one
this is another cool endgame that is why
to move and what should white do some of
the things to consider is that first of
all your King is much more active than
his King and what you can do is to
calculate and figure out what does black
ones does black one so you come over
here can you five if you figure out what
black wants to do then you can try to
block it yes good job everyone
in the last one thank you for giving me
full lines and that's just winning that
end game is just yep
um
Kingi file is very tempting but you have
something more accurate
yes good job h4 so the idea of HR is no
more King g5 and if King comes f5 you
can just play g3 no King g4 cuz of
Bishop e6 and now that here is fixed
then you can go after this guy so what
if Knight goes to b8
um
[Music]
so remember how we talked about what
black wants to get the king over here
now that the night is not there and that
is possible so maybe you could think
about a way to keep the black king away
Bishop b5 is interesting but I think the
problem with Bishop b5 is that it's too
chilled because let's say you try to go
after that it's possible to take King g3
push yeah
and then this would be a draw so be
careful to not let your opponent slip
like this that's why the better move is
not Bishop b5 and it's um something to
try and block the king coming in from to
g4 Bishop d3 interesting I believe
Bishop d3 is good something slightly
more precise than Bishop d3 I haven't
seen that move in the chat yet wish up
d4 is not possible Bishop d3 it's good
but King e4 good but again not the most
precise so think about it another way -
where do you want so the king is going
to gets here and that's when the real
danger is right so just flip it should
be - take that take that square of it
because f5 isn't dangerous G flat g4 is
dangerous great King Lear I believe you
were the first one to save a show B -
good job and so the idea is if you were
to just play King f5 sure I just played
g3 you cannot get in anywhere now I just
play king d5 maybe Bishop f3 eventually
Kings e5 just go after these pawns or
instead of trying to play something like
g3 I could just bringing the King
or I could even consider taking over
here so my my point is that there are
options there are a lot of options so
let's say King e6 what do you want to do
now
so the point is eventually at some point
later you're gonna take this guy so you
want your pieces to be ready when you
take that to start push push push
so that's that's what's something you
could work around g3 is interesting king
c5 maybe but you want your King to come
to the Kings side so those of you who
are saying king he four are correct and
black is now also in some sort of a
zooks long if King goes to here you just
can't go there
if King goes to f6 King can go to d5 so
that's why blacks try to play something
like ninety seven just be careful not to
blunder your stuff you know the usual
looking at for first and then take and
just chilled out bring your king and
then start pushing your pawns so yeah it
is it it's the whole game followed a
very logical path and you didn't let
your opponent's get too creative and try
to slip away too much so that is the
theme that we are going for right now
this one is for action move and I know
these are not as interesting and then
like as like the tactics and all of
those fun stuff that's we were doing but
it's still a good idea to know how to
win their equal looking end games and
that's why I'm doing it today and then
after that we have the conspire of
searching step to cheer you up a little
bit you want to see me in banter blitz
why not
so this one is blacks a movie you can
already see some stuff that our
advantage could be considered advantage
towards black first of all this show
begins night
second of all the activated King so
those are some stuff that you can start
to work around and the I think the main
question is how to get your king in
possible it could become it could happen
from mixed exchange of Slav nice p6
interesting but that doesn't help your
King gets in you know we want to play if
I don't know why if I was I think if
I've is worth considering I don't think
it's the best move
mainly because if you play e5 you are
giving your opponent some squares and
stuff to start jumping around so that's
would be my reason for not playing E 5
and yeah king c6 B 6 a 5 so your first
move should be King C 6 and then you
will be faced with King F 2 so now how
do you want to get get in how do you
want to get your pieces in
this is this is actually quite long end
game until we reached the winning
position so it is not it's not like a
chop chop Winton as you guys can hold er
the gas so you can't just bring the King
in cuz the knife whoops because the
night is here so you have to get a
little creative and move some other
pieces around a little bit
yes the shop moving the bishop is the
best one ideally not Bishop c4 because
you want to try and keep you and Bishop
even if taking is not the best idea you
want to try and keep your Bishop so
that's why Bishop a4 is the better one
you're just enforcing pressure even
though you're allowing King hu but he
gets your king in you get your king in a
little bit more in now now what do you
do so you see that your position
improved since the first position that
we saw but how do you actually finish
the game off
yes you are correct you don't want us to
move the night until so that this square
is very important you don't want your
opponent to get the night here because
then if this knife gets free the other
knife will jump to v3 and it will cause
a lot of unpleasant situations and
remember how I hate to give my opponent
any chance and I've been when someone
asked me what is my chess of style I
tell them snake style you just like go
around to your opponent then Shh
basically putting pressure and not
letting the opponent's slip away like a
snake most of the time so that is why I
wouldn't touch this night before he
touches his night so not 96 so one thing
that you can realize is okay so your
night is doing a good job here you don't
want to change the pawn structure your
king is great there is your bishop doing
anything there could you improve the
bishop yes probably some of you said
this before but pond to pond Tokyo is
the first one that I'm seeing that said
this should be five so good job and you
are gonna go over here thank you
boa or Python either one I'll take votes
let's combine them bow are tied okay so
you bring in the bishop and you're gonna
go over here to d3 so that is why why to
try to cover cover up the d3 square
because if you get Bishop d3 it's
extremely unpleasant and it might even
be creating some nating mating nets so
night c1 now this Knight is free there
is no more pressure on c5 squares so you
bring in your knight
you see how everything is moving
together and how like all of the pieces
have this nice coordination so so now
White has this
King freed up a little cuz the a2 is
defended by c1 so King up what do you do
now so another thing another important
topic in like middle game endgame or any
of any part of chess when you have
advantage is to convert those advantages
so you can come you can see that you
have spatial advantage and your pieces
are more active but at some point you
have to realize that even though your
pieces are really nicely placed there's
always something that you can improve
and something that you can't try to
possibly exchange off so that is that's
one of those situations that it's a good
idea to have keep an open mind and that
is why here 94 is a good idea especially
because if you take I just think with
the bishop and I'm going for a 2 so what
you can do is just put the King back and
eventually you're gonna get into zoogs
wrong situation and I'm going to take
your pawn when you move the King away or
if you go King a1 that is also very
unpleasant because eventually I'm gonna
the bishop can come and take the other
pawns and this is very very in favor of
black so that's why knight can take
tickets but I'm also attacking III so
the knight goes all the way back to the
first rank you can't see how the like
pieces are super cool position than
everything so keeping that in mind what
do you want to do as black
Michelle Bay for interesting
but you have some some you have a move
that is more heightened like Bishop a4
is good but you have a better move you
have a stronger move
Nightbeat you good job great minds beat
you you were talking f1 so nice tries to
run away and now what should you do
this move is actually kind of different
than the written so if you don't find it
don't be don't feel weird this is this
is one of those moves so just think
about it and if you find it great if not
no don't worry about it
May 5 is interesting but so the 9th came
to g3 and night could possibly cause
some discomfort if night jumps to h5 so
yes g6 very very good job you take away
the edge 5 square so now white tries to
get some stuff with E for now what do
you want to do
the ship c4 Wow interesting
I think Bishop c4 is nice-looking in the
game they played 98 for I believe Bishop
c4 is good as well but I think 94 is
interesting because it takes away than
the King c3 ideas but Bishop c4 should
have been good enough as well take take
now see this Knight doesn't really have
anywhere to go
not c2 not safe on this night is kind of
completely cut off so white tries to
bring in the night and now how do you
use this spatial and just really good
position how do you use it how do you
continue
yeah this shop have fun good job
everyone and you are eventually going to
get some of these guys because if g3 you
just come here and say pick up this one
ranek Knight f2 you pick this one up so
now now you have spacial advantage your
pieces are more active and you have a
pawn up so we'll have to be very careful
and finish the job
how what would be your next move as
black
a five is very interesting h6 also
interesting but I think the main
question is which piece which one of
your pieces is not active and how you
can activate that better that is there
any piece that feels like its job is
done and you want to move it to a better
place
I wouldn't apply f5 just because it
feels a little too early and you
wouldn't know if you want f5 h5 you
don't want to give a clear target to
your opponent that's why I wouldn't play
a 5 but so I guess what I'm trying to
say it's ok this Bishop here is doing
something useful so let it be what about
the knight is the nice being useful
kinda is taking away this is square this
is square what about the King could you
bring in the King to go attack something
else so yes you can bring in the King so
King before night b3 and now remember
how we talked about thinking about if
it's the time to do some exchange baby
so this is one of those times to
consider if he wants to do any sort of
exchange or not
um f5 is is still interesting but you
have something a little bit more
decisive
keep trying to keep putting pressure so
let me ask you a question
yeah Bishop b4 good one I was going to
ask do you think if Bishop a4 take is
this a winning endgame because if this
is a winning endgame then you should
television before you should give your
opponent the chance to make the mistake
Bishop b4 from Barcelona and good on so
visually this show before not white
won't take if white wants to try and
have any sort of survival chances white
should not take so king d2 now you bring
in the Knight to c3 so those of you who
suggest that Knight c3 good job it's in
the move order now why it tries to put
more pressure with 95 now how do you try
and finish off the game there are few
moves left and there's still a lot of
pressure to be puts
yes Knight c3 after Knight c3 c5 a5 good
job
so after 85 white is pretty tied up so
the only tiny streaks that's white could
do is maybe to do a 3 and BIC please
take me so I can take C 3 so a 3 king C
4 obviously and white tries to bring in
more pressure with King III and try to
maybe take a pawn or something and try
chances an endgame
also King the East King c4 you were
attacking d4 so King III is the only
move now what do you do is black
there's one really cute this is actually
pretty cute move you put want to say it
hello let me I'll give you few more
seconds before I give up the answer
No
so I have a lot of f5s diamond con or
bishop
so the thing is if you put your Bishop
over here this Bishop is paralyzing this
one and this one so it's like such a
cool square and after episode five none
of these Knights gonna actually get in
so white can't try this chances with
like the 97 but you get a four check
King B 5 try to go away and you finally
get that pawn try not to rush because it
is I mean you can just take it right now
but Knight c3 and you would lose a4 or
d5 so that's why I play Bishop C to keep
all of your pawns together strong and
next move this guy is coming so this was
actually a very brilliant game by you
Sokolov I really really enjoyed it I
don't know about you guys but it was
very interesting to just watch how
someone like you so poof it that's high
chess understanding just keeps putting
pressure all the sides remember first
from this position you got two
disposition so a position equal ish
looking black brought in the King
brought in the night push the bishop to
the other side and start as gets and
started to get advantage on the other
side and just completely just went all
over the board and when won the game so
that was actually a very cool game I
really hope you guys enjoy you guys
enjoyed it so what about this one what
do you think this position should happen
or what do you think the position needs
thank you for the birthday wishes are we
calling it a birthday week we can do
that too
not really had 48 hours
mmm I don't think this was an ROC
so yeah this is why to move let me know
what you think why should do and what
realistically what is the results
so we're having some stuff about Bishop
before as for ef5 ok ef5 interesting
yeah King Lear you're correct so the
idea is take take f4 and the Knight f3
now do you think this position how is it
is it just is it good is it bad
who do you want to be
so that yeah that's the thing this is
actually a very equal dryish position
and it was kinda blanket so kudos to
whoever said if this is a cuppa Blanca
game and yeah alright let's go to the
next one this is I mean this position
still has a lot to like look over there
could be 95 you can consider rookie one
there's a lot of things to consider but
realistically between high level players
there's not much to actually fight for
so what about this one white team move
things might be getting a little bit
more spicy
so any
I'm 95 check you have something much
more interesting than 95 or an IP one
three four I mean I said spicy are you
trying to spice it up for your opponent
so this poem is kind of pushy pushy but
the right kind of pushy pushy 95 ok 95
is interesting but your biggest problem
is that night on d7 you can't attack it
because let's say 95 take take how are
you gonna get this night out of there
you can't play Bishop b6 because that
creates weakness on your bishop can't go
anywhere so this would be kind of dead
so what would you do nice a4 good job
for all of you Fuu spiced it up taking
is equal to losing you take my four
comes to c4 and then the a 4 a 4 is
pretty much dead already so you can't
really take it let's say Bishop b3 what
do you do now
yes um 95 I think it's kind of I think
it serves the same purpose but there is
something stronger yes 96 so the thing
is my c5 is a strong but what if take
then we are gonna take it with the pond
it is a strong because you get this e6
and e7 but it's better to have this as
past pond and taking on d1 isn't really
smart because just take over here if
King e6 95 and then take through this
guy because everything is a check so
96-86 take now what do you do
this is this was a spicy right see here
so Pope doesn't only show the games that
he won he shows the games that his
opponent played beautifully - I try to
do that you know I tried to do that too
in my classes but it's kind of painful
Oh true the Josh is correct suit if 95
Bishop e6 kind of holds everything
together so yeah Knight b6 just
sometimes goes better with the guts
because Knight b6 you are attacking more
and you're enforcing that exchange
yep p7 is a good one roof p8 seems to be
the only kind of reasonable way to try
but take take and t7 and this is already
really lost isn't it
baby coins now these are not basically
is there full-grown coins at this point
okay so next one are you guys still not
tired of these boring the looking end
games
so this is White's to move and I know I
know we all hate track and games but we
gotta know it's to be honest I would
prefer to do end games all day every day
if I never have to do organic chemistry
again but can't do that have an exam
coming up and in the final coming up
then I'll be free but so how do you want
to use your advantage in this position
so I have a suggestion of rookie five
but okay so the first thing to do
especially in end games with little
pieces left is to think about is this
endgame better winning for me in the
pawn it again
so if the rooks are off the board now
then the opponent game is winning right
so that's why you could you should go an
offer rook exchange and now push so now
you have you are two pawns you are upon
up and you have partially cut the king
but your king is also cut so you have to
play it's really smart to be able to
treat your King and keep the pawn and
all of those cool stuff so let's say
King f7 what do you want to do
so yeah you can bring in the King to
beat you so bring in the King bring in
the king and now what do you do
g4 is interesting but earlier on but you
kind of need your Jeep on to keep
everything like a glue
so yeah good job
g3 glue keep your pawns don't you're not
in a rush then bring in your King slowly
slowly
now check which side you are going to go
so you could use the idea of the
triangle stuff a little bit and so my
advice is right now instead of starting
to calculate moves moves moves try to
calculate try to imagine a position in
which black would be in some sort of a
zoogs along
that would have to move the king or move
the rook and then you would you would
you could use that tempie
so yeah you do you put your King on see
for your clothes back now what how will
you win this end game
now I have bad bad shoulders
King I'm still not seeing the move guys
I broke g6 you don't want to give up
you're a fun
a5 pawn king d4 king d4
No okay so rooks a sex is something that
you should do after you've done this
triangle idea King bee tree good job
King bee tree so if King me tree King d6
now you get king before so basically you
are just waiting you are just waiting
for a move if your opponent gives you
check you could consider something like
King a two emphasizing and considering
because if King a two now your pawn is
safe and now you want to take G 6 even
though your king is a little too passive
but you get to get you get the chance to
eat the pawn but that's why that's black
one touch the rope and black would play
king d6 I would also like to point out
that black is the world champion maxilla
with so he's not just some random guy
that we don't know about who doesn't
know endgame so he knew what he was
doing and he still got a little bit
stuck
so king d6 king before now this is that
brilliant idea because check King here
Ruka won now the king has to go in see
so in this position after you k1 the
King couldn't go in so you wanted to get
the same position just with the King a
little bit away so you could play king
b5 everyone good so and you get to play
king b5 check King a six king c6 and you
eat the pawn and happily ever after King
bee tree is a very cool looks long right
okay so any questions on this
hopefully ya know what's the few more of
distant games and then we look at the
power of game so this one is white to
move and first of all what do you think
should is the hoodie thing has advantage
and depending on your answer then you
know what to push for
well the Dennis Dennis Miller that's the
thing a lot of these positions you
probably wouldn't have you probably if
you just looked at it for the first time
you wouldn't know honestly you wouldn't
know so that's why we do this homeworks
and puzzles and classes and just look
into different positions so when it
happens in the game then you're like oh
yeah I remembered that idea I saw it in
the guy who played against Lila and he
beats him so good night good night
supple so that's that's kind of why
that's why we do this that's why we try
to take our time and go over them Black
has better pieces on more active game
King true it is wise to move
94 is interesting but nice a one so good
job to those of you who say 91 and the
idea is that after 91 you are gonna go
try and put the knight on d3 and then
see if the knight can go anywhere better
or then you can just try to do like King
c4 so 93 to t2 not allow King c4 Knight
e3 now what do you think blacks should
do
so some of the things to think about for
what the block should do is you see
black has a space and black seems to
have the special advantage but one
problem that's coming up right now is
nice a five now if I would be attacking
this guy and attacking the knight on c3
so that's something that you could work
on King D 5 D 5 is interesting but what
would you do after a night before check
and then knight c6 because you can't
bring in the King in so you have to go
back and then a seven-pound so
so 92 is very interesting
mainly because let's say if you play
nights before now trying to go to c6
square well one possibility that I can
think of is flowing after d4 so maybe
maybe something like 94 taketake and
then the bishop comes to g1 and goes to
h2 and all of these pawns are looking
kind of weirdest so that's why you
wouldn't sled to your opponent's place
such a move such as Knight d4 so after
92 you see Knights d4 is potentially
uncomfortable so you just play King c4
put your king in a cool place Knight c3
now what do you want to do you could
bring the King back and just see what if
your client wants to repeat but you have
a better chance after Knight c3 what do
you want to do with white
gobble gobble that's a good idea yeah so
king c4 Knight c3 attacking a four
thank you
I can imagine
yep we have doubled up today
Clarett we are considering your legal
moves perfect okay so a five is the move
you guys should be seriously considering
and the idea of a five as well if you
take which you kind of have to I take
this guy and now I have this super cool
passed on and you can't really stop it
you could try to bring in the night and
see what the hell occurs what happens
then
but even trying that so you eliminated
the idea of 93 and 92 is not that
dangerous but still you would want to
have some protection for this guy so
what would you do
yeah what's up how are you guys doing
Marcus we did have a lot of blitz
happening just right before he started
to switch to YouTube we have we had a
bunch of blitz playing and stuff and the
class before that on our twitch channel
and yes I I am mixing it up we have few
more puzzles to cover up about strategic
and games and then we'll switch to how
to beat Kasparov in 13 steps I don't
think he's going to like seeing that but
well if he sees it sure he can
okay so 91 is interesting what 95 is the
best one
you push push if take take check if you
don't really care about this one anymore
and you get the chance to you have to to
cool past ponds and black isn't black
can't stop them boats or you could even
give this check first if you want to so
95 92 was played first King d5 is
interesting but King d5 wasn't played
King d3 was played King d5 I
I'm thinking might have the only thing
that I can see about why this isn't good
this wasn't played was maybe a four but
a four there's always be six and King e6
and this is just really good for whites
anyways so I feel like those of them are
good moves if you guys actually know
what is why King d5 wasn't played let me
know and so King d3 Knight b3 Bishop III
always doing that paralysis idea
a4 I'll slowly slowly bringing your king
and now this is just winning cuz this
guy is falling there's all these ideas
of picking up the bishop and yeah this
was a very interesting game all right
okay so I'm gonna put this position up
and I'm gonna ask in the chat because
they have done a lot of puzzles already
do you guys want to do few more puzzles
maybe two three more puzzles or you want
to switch it to the Kasparov game cuz my
mood is kind of for Kasparov game and we
could pick up the end games and other
time because we have a lot of end games
to go over all the time so this position
is up here for those of you who want to
think about it think about it for those
of you who wants to switch it up let me
know
so we have more puzzles to kasparov two
puzzles to kasparov two puzzles three
Kasparov or Kasparov five six who if you
have a lot of Kasparov face okay let's
let's switch it to that virus so if you
want you can take a picture of this and
next time I'm doing and games so either
Tuesday or Thursday I will start with
this one so feel free to have that
somewhere and think about it so alright
this is the Kasparov game and the idea
is I actually I'm showing you this game
from the book called Giants of strategy
from neo McDonald two thousand seven or
nine he wrote two books oh yeah
Giants of strategy engines of power play
I really really like these two books I
think those would be among my favorite
ones definitely and so this one this
book this specific game was very
interesting because it the in the book
they actually called it how to beat
Kasparov and thirteen steps and I just
love that title and I've been dying to
show it in one of my classes okay so
this is a game between Karpov and
Kasparov in World Championship in 1990
the this is game 17 well okay good how
could I help my my feelings bubbling
about coffee so
Karpov is a huge just she plays I mean
all of the like a lot of openings a 44
but I remember that's in their matches
d4 goes played a lot like Queen's Gambit
King the Queen's Indian sorry not
Queen's Gambit Queen ski Queen's Indian
name is an Indian there are a lot of
lots of dos plate and so this is
actually exchange groom felt which is
just as cool maybe slightly cooler
I played groom felt a while ago and I
liked it I really liked how active it
was and so so far it's mainly theory and
both players are just trying to get the
pieces out so that's why I'm just going
over it's quite quickly because I really
want to get to the steps and so you with
both players you are just trying to
develop normally you put that Knight to
c6 Bishop belongs on g7 Bishop on g4 is
a little wobbly so most likely you're
going to have to relocate it there you
go
and you still ask twice you still have
kind of to finish the developments you
probably think this bishop belongs
either on c4 or d3 well the king is
definitely going to do short castle so
you try to do the short castle and some
soft like Knight c4 might work but
there's always this b7 that's hanging at
the end so that's why Kasparov tried to
bring the bishop instead of the night b5
to put some more enforcement on c4
square
Asics just to bring more protection
now exchanging the Bishop of exchanging
a pair of rooks and so this is the first
position that you could start to think
about and so this is actually step one
of 13 and so the position looks kind of
equal is and you could think that well I
could get some advantage because the
Queen Saipan majority and all but Karpov
is going to show you how you can start
these 13 steps and you are going to
exploit the open C file with drug C 1
and so step 1 you put the rope on the
open file so Rick C 1 after X C One
Nights C 4 isn't really good idea
because of 92 so the only pretty much
the only logical move is Queen d7 now
what do you think should be step 2
thank you guys for all the positive
positive comments and positivity very
nice 17 1:7 so step two you could
consider a very very nice creating a
very nice outpost for your night with
white queen a tree is interesting but we
don't really do much trading the bishop
um not yet Queen a tree is interesting
but it's what would you do after night
c4 so d5 good job good job fragrance d5
so your step two is to advance the D
pawn and you creates this pretty cool
outpost for your knight Knight comes to
c4 okay so 9 c4 is the move that was
played and rook c8 is the move that's
worth considering but the problem is
take take and you lose the pawn so well
I could bring the knight into the game
but that's that knight on e5 is really
really what's the right word just not in
the game just the easiest website is
just not in the game and white already
got this past pond and E 5 could be
coming so that's really pleasant for
black so 94 trying to bring in the night
so step 3
this Knight is a knowing remove the
obstruction from
file how do you want to do that
offside Graham yeah there you go baby
baby clean on d5 true so step one you
got the C file step two
you play d5 got the outpost on c6 step 3
remove the annoying lights and someone
just say the word a four is interesting
but not the right kind of interesting 92
good job easy 92 take now step four
you're going to prevent black from
creating an outpost like black using
doubt sorry you are going to prevent
black from creating an outpost of his
own on the C file so you are going to
take it with the bishop because if you
took it through the clean now black gets
to do the outpost with b4 and then
Bishop c3 is coming and then black is
blocking your C file so you don't want
to do that so that is why in order to
keep the control of c3 squared you gotta
take it to the bishop so that was your
step for rook c8 now what do you want to
do I'm going to wait on a little bit
before announcing what neo McDonald said
as a step 5
but this is a very cool game and I very
much enjoyed his commentary on this and
the way he puts the steps so I wish I
just I wish I could start to do a
commentary more like that I'm actually
going to try I have tried a little bit
on step stepping it but it's just not
this beautiful well I mean I'm not
carpooled so
but mercy six very good job you're very
good King Lear what is your reigning
Brooks e6 and the idea is very simple
Step five you're going to sneeze control
out the output square that you created
on step two with d5 so you're looking
you're gonna look at the tactical stuff
and be like okay so if take oops take if
the Queen takes then you have check and
Bishop h6 which is a force mate and that
is why rook c6 black wouldn't take it
after rook c6 what do you think black
should do actually let's get some input
on what black should do
so for black we sell drugs c6 doesn't
work so Africa c6 doesn't work you kind
of have to be able to play something
with black right so Bishop e5 seems to
be the only one because you're kind of
evacuating the the g7 square and now you
want to take on c6 because at the end if
Queen d8 King g7 and you get to run away
a little bit so this should be five now
now rook takes c6 is a threat what would
you want to do or we can ask what would
Karpov - so W w ke D
it is tough for black but after Bishop
e5 it's quite a mo
so what which one should whites do Queen
c2 is interesting but you have something
really stronger so let me tell you what
is the problem of Queen c2 if Queen c2
rook takes c6 you take with the pond
Queen c7 and the problem is how can you
you can't really just break through this
blockade on c7 and that's why we have
step six you are going to force the
black Bishop from the excellent e5
square so that is why you as white are
going to push the bishop away it's just
someone tell me how f4 is fr is
unnecessary risk so for those of you who
are suggesting a for unnecessary risk I
see mark and set bishop c3 if someone
earlier said that sorry that's just the
first one I saw Bishop c3 is the good
one Bishop c3 you are pushing this
bishop away and the thing is if Bishop
takes c3 Queen takes c3 if work takes
now you take with D and now that's a
giant pass pawn and if roukoz t8 queen
comes to c5 and this is just way too
much pressure and struck c7 also coming
up taking up in 57 it is just one of
those doughnut those positions where you
just wish you weren't black so that's
what would happen after Bishop c3 now
what do you think would happen after
rook takes c6
so again when you play a move such as
Bishop c3 it's a brilliant move but you
have to have calculated the best
possibilities for your opponent so the
logical candidate moves are first of all
checks not really any logical checks
here then Bishop takes Bishop takes on
c3 rook takes on c6 and the last one the
bishop to move somewhere else
Bishop moving away relaxed bishop from
afar moving away let's say to be eight
or somewhere and so those those should
be the three the three moves that you
calculate for black so you take TC and
for example Queen comes to c7 you
exchange these check and push and that's
already a clean ground Queen at this
point okay so my point was to try and
get you guys to be comfortable with
calculating the best monster your
opponent as well so Bishop say three
words calculating rook c6 worth
calculating and so Bishop b8 is the only
one that is not losing on spot and now
Karpov is getting to step seven and you
are going to put the Queen on d4 simply
threatening bye-bye
mate and you are also going to ideally
if well not if when flack stops the main
threat with only possible have six then
you are going to complete your step 7
and put the Queen on the super cool and
crucial c5 square
you can you can't delay playing clean
c-5 a little bit because you could try
and play Queen c3 which is another cool
way and the main point is that you are
just getting in touch with this square
and you are also weakening the black
king so let's look at f6 so right now
black is try something if it was black
say move again and let's say Y didn't do
anything black would take and if you
give check hang up
take take so you don't want this
position to happen because you don't
want your Bishop to be hanging down here
so going back to this position after f6
now you know if it's black so move again
black would take your rook and attack
your bishop and your bishop would be
hanging in at the end right so in order
to avoid that hanging of your Bishop you
should do what all right so now boy you
guys think a little bit about it I'm
going to read the chat music I believe
there would be some there's a point to
my understanding music on YouTube is not
really recommended I don't know enough
about it Tracy
let's see what else know there was a
question about music on YouTube
Tracy's laughing I believe it so I'm
like I wish I was like a DJ had this
like huge set and then there was like an
exciting scene coming up I would play
something dated in some smoke could come
up some cool ideas right but well my yay
yes good job
do you want to move the bishop dish of a
five so this number five is really
paralyzing all of these and all of these
squares as well
and so let me let me look at Queen c5
for a second so Queen c5 I believe there
is still the issue of you taking and I
taking in Queen c7 and this is still
pretty stuck I think that's one of the
reasons Queen c5 is not played also
I think that's actually I think that's
the only reason because Bishop like this
is going to be taken to check so you
can't play anything else you have to
move the rope and taking is the best one
and even if you were to take with the
Queen I am not sure how you're going to
win this with whites because there's a
clear path for black schemes to get
there and it's foot at least create
unnecessary complications so that's why
Bishop a5 always just keep pushing put
the pressure and yep okay so
Bishop a5 and black white Bishop d6
Bishop e5 is possible too but then you
just play queen c5 and now that you're
controlling this critical c7 square
after take take just Queen c7 can't be
any more or even taking what clean is
pretty cool too because well this Bishop
c5 doesn't exist anymore so step 7 was
to play this Queen d4 and we can the
Kings side and bring in the Queen to
control more of the Queen side as well
now step 8
after f6 is to put the bishop on 85 to
control c7 square which is a very
crucial 7th rank point so Bishop a5
Bishop d6 whoops Bishop d6 and now this
should be easy to find move for everyone
and anyways I'm just going to stay what
is step 9 step 9 to support a rook and
gain the control of this C file so that
thing said what do you think is the move
yep Queen City good job everyone so if
black were to take take this is just
next what we see seven and this is
already like I wish I had that button
did it do just like going all the way
down I tried okay
so black tries to play with c8 and at
this point we are reaching our step 10
black is kind of powerless so you're
going to make some useful consolidating
moves before increasing a pressure on
the C file so what do you think are
these consolidating moves for white
while you think of that I'm gonna look
at the chat I have some pursing friends
over here cool
hello you are a chest trick addict so am
I
what's form a group
question - do I do this sessions it kind
of depends but for this week and next
week I am teaching Tuesdays Thursdays
Fridays and Sundays we'll see what
happens after that but the same stir the
same schedule that's going to hold for
next week as well so tomorrow we have
the tactics and King and war King and
pawn warfare so tune in for those a3 Wow
proud of you guys a tree good good one
good job
and then g3 wow you guys are on fire
black tries to just play some move like
King g7 g3 nasty Queen f6 maybe but it's
more it's not what the position is your
pieces are already super ly good placed
you don't really need to give your
opponent chances a3 is great g3 is great
so let's say Bishop e5 you bringing the
clean h5 and Kasparov is trying to move
some some stuff he moved the rook away
but it's but the problem for whites is
that white doesn't have can't play
district c7 yet because of this bishop
so you will your rook cants just your
two can't invade them c7 square just yet
so what do you think you should do hint
step 11 is to drive the black bishop
away from this defense on c7
f-for good move but something less
chance giving to your opponent bishop c7
great now what do you think blacks
should do I'm gonna give you guys a
minute to just absorb the position give
me some ideas on what black should do
and what's what with whites do in
response to that
stern you are funny
so what do you guys think is happening
what's your recommendation
so first of all if you take I just take
and East Evan is bye-bye
so now you can't really take it and
we've seen it I don't think it works you
just take on e5 and that's also
tactically kind of dead so the only
thing that's black could try to do is
push away one and now the thing is
Bishop a1 you already gave up the c7
square so the step 12 of 13 to do for
white please to clear the c7 square for
the rook without letting this bishop
come back c5 so what would the move be
I'm glad I'm keeping good some GM's
interested I thought you guys already
know all of these games
TRL gray I'm a huge fan of dark team
so you guys already know steps step 12
but what do you think is the move for it
Bishop a4 great good job
so now if you were to play which would
be five I would just take it and Roxy
seven already bye-bye Bishop a4 Queen d7
was like the only move to try and play
and step thirteen you seize the seventh
rank and party rook c7 so this is a step
thirteen black all the blacks opposition
down the C file have been crushed you
push the rook away you push the bishop
away and Kasparov is kind of unable to
prevent the decision to just you can't
stop the rooks e7 and also another fun
little treats is this D for the D pawn
cause when you play like Queen D aids
what do you think is coming exactly d6
is coming up now you now you're
understanding more about
step 7 you remember step 7 was Queen d4
that you started you attacked for mate
and also started to weaken the King side
so that's the value of step 7 + f6
really weakened the king and so this is
a really uncomfortable so Kasparov tried
to play something like g5 and what would
you do as white
Oh what's happened last Sunday Easter
Easter happened so the clock was closed
on Easter and yeah so hold on I still
want to move from you guys what what
should White's do how are you going to
beat Kasparov
Muraki seven is interesting Bishop g5 I
think kind of interesting but you would
be giving your opponent unnecessary
chances you have something way more
first forceful and just pushy pushy and
d7 thank you
so Bishop g5 is interesting but exactly
like you have something that you know
you're gonna win for sure
rookie seven also interesting but d7
like 27 yeah it keeps the black Queen
Andrew just kind of stuck there why
would you play your key seven to freedom
okay it's now you there are few more
moves so bear with me and tell me what
would you do as White
these are pretty cool moves i Anika's
borrow fan as well but it's always fun
to watch
um
maybe all of them goes you're saying is
a big maybe but be careful with your
bishop hanging here or you just want to
give it up yes Bishop d2 a5 very nice
we should eat you you are going to go to
85 let's say Bishop e5 what do you do
um
[Music]
so
after Bishop d2 Bishop e5 you ideally
don't want to give your rook up and you
want to try your best to keep your
pieces so yeah
rook p7 and so here I believe Kasparov
resigned but the thing is there's just
no good moves and let's see if it's wise
to move again white can simply play
Queen something like Queen eight seven
and then take over here and then play
Bishop a5 and there's nothing that black
would do to stop it and so yeah there's
that that's how you beat Kasparov and
the other problem is if you as blacks
just move your queen anywhere well if
you move it there there's also this
check so never mind but if you just
generally try to move your queen I mean
if you could there's also Bishop a5
coming so it's it's a whole mess let's
say you try to play like I'm just
brainstorming King f7 to keep this guy
and again you don't really you can't
really do much because this least of all
like super super least of all so that is
how you beat Kasparov in 13 steps the
steps are really cool and that's
something that I try to do with my games
when I go back and I look at them and
that's really interesting I don't think
that's I don't think that those carpools
preparation like I'm gonna do step one
this step to that but it's turned out
pretty cool it is kind of a zoo song but
I mean the position is really sucky
sucky so it's it's just not really lives
long - alright so I'm gonna switch back
to few more puzzles so we can wrap it up
with more puzzles so now
you saw the power of strategic game so
you saw how knowing strategy can help
you get this dispositions and so yeah it
is very much worth it all right
so whoops we did this puzzle already
this one so we left off at this puzzle
earlier and I wasn't sure how long the
13 steps would take so how do you think
this game is gonna turn out so we
already looked at this position but yeah
just let me know what you think it is
wise to move and strategy strategy
strategy
so why it is indeed better b5 is
interesting but you still have a lot to
do in the kingside before you come to
the Queen side because logically Queen
side is where you are going to actually
win so like most likely you are going to
be able to take the b6 pawn and push the
beef beep on to clean most likely and so
in order to get that you need to do
other stuff in the king side to be able
to get to that Queen side so it is why
to move
yes h4 good job you guys h4 h5 now what
do you do
Bishop III is interesting but Bishop
Caesar is better mainly because you are
just not giving that d4 square to the
night so Bishop c3 bust a king goes to
eh attack your rook p7 logical King d8
now what do you do as Boaz white
why to move what do you want to do
b5b 595 be careful guys
Bishop d2 no 94
nope nope don't touch the peep on
yeah route p8 and now
well if King goes to c7 you can't do
this through cached stuff and go after
this guy so that's why I can go to e7
and you still can't try for rook h8 but
[Music]
g6 and the you can't release that you
can't get this one if the King was on c7
then you could get the phone but now
King f7 and protects the pond so Lucas
it doesn't work now what do you guys do
g4 is interesting but b5 finally you
finally get to do your b5 and 1295
doesn't really make any more sense
so Brooke d6 you bring out your king 95
now now you have a pretty logical slash
cool move what would you do now
be shot before good job you guys what
after rook t4 kind of have to play Kings
t3 as your only move check where do you
go now
you could play King c4 but the problem
is you don't really want the repetition
fun fact I played with black Roseanne
Tellez in 2015 I lost pretty badly but
that's that's one of the games that I
might show because my opponents wait so
nice but yeah King c2 rook d4 what do
you do now
you don't want perpetual so no more king
c3
hmm
you don't want to take on c5 just yet
because you have a better move and then
you can't yeah rook beef 7 check and
then you take so now this endgame is
winning you take this pawn and you play
with p7 i I went through these moves
because they were easy and I mean
logical so now King f8 now how do you
try and finish the game off
v6 is interesting but maybe bring some
pieces up yes these moose played by
Roseanne Tellez and Yusupov and me yes
we are trying to go over why they did
what they did and how we can try to
teach ourselves to do that in our games
so that's it that's the basic idea so
thanks a tree let's say King g8 trying
to protect these guys over here and now
what do you do how do you actually get
your pieces to go in a little bit
yep g4 good job taketake and king g8 so
you see the thing is with the in the
bedrock end game with beep on I don't
know how to exactly show it but the kids
it's good to have the King between AJ's
and g8 because hold on I don't want to
say it's wrong because alright let's say
I'm just going to brainstorm just for a
second and let's say if right now you
play King f7 is blunder cuz of ricochet
to take and you lose the roof so that's
why that's why user Roseanne Tellez is
trying to keep his king between 88 and
g8 so he can keep it between h7 and g7
but because of this age pan that's not
going to pay off so 3/4 you query for to
create the age five to eight to create
the H pass pawn so now you have to pass
pawns
so eventually at the end of the lines
one of these still are going to become
queen basically so and here he just kind
of gave up and took the pawn went back
and now how would you finish off the
game as white
yes Trixie seven good job well what's
the black tried to just survive a little
bit longer and not really doing much of
it because there's a queen on the board
so yeah I have a lot of these kind of
puzzles the strategic ones and mixed
with some dynamic don't really have
another how to beat Kasparov tutorial
but I will try to try to comment on the
games then do them like step by step
because that seems to work very well and
I am doing end game and tactics tomorrow
5 to 7 so be sure to tune in for those
and I am glad you guys enjoyed today
session see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you